hi there this is a bonus video it's not
one of my regularly scheduled videos
it's not really about language learning
it's about the importance of disagreeing
the importance of entertaining different
points of view and recognizing that
people don't always have to agree and
the reason I'm doing this is because I'm
a little bit peeved I should say having
just had a look at the video that the
interview that I did with with Matt Matt
versus Japan on his channel and I
referenced it in the discussion we had
in Japanese I think there was a link in
the description box at any rate I'll
make sure that there's a link here where
we spoke for about thirty minutes most
of it in English most of it was Matt
explaining how he went about learning
Japanese and his approach to learning
Japanese and what has prompted me to
make this video is is as I review their
comments I'm just absolutely taken aback
by the amount of sort of venom and
hostility that is expressed by the vast
majority of people commenting on this
video and there are a lot of them and
the gist of it is that I am close-minded
I don't want to you know accept Matt's
way of learning Japanese probably I
can't speak Japanese anyway and you know
you can go there and have a look but I
looked at this as a kind of holy cow but
it's part of a larger phenomenon and
this is the sort of phenomenon that that
somehow we are not allowed to disagree I
have to be blown away with whatever Matt
is doing I have to consider that so
wonderful when in fact I don't think
that I think that he
is perfectly entitled to pursue you know
the enth degree of perfection in
Japanese which is a perfectly valid
thing to pursue and I said that I
thought it was certainly that's what his
choices that's what he chooses to do but
I have a different approach and my
approach is that I like to learn a lot
less in less depth about a number of
languages but even that in the comments
is considered to be you know very
amateurish and dilettante ish and so
forth and so on but you know I've also
made the point in our original
discussion that that whatever he wants
to pursue in Japanese greater depth of
knowledge and some aspect of Japanese
all of this comes through more
engagement with the language more
listening you want to know more about
business Japanese you listen to and read
more business Japanese you want to do
more on history you do more reading and
listening on history you will never
cover at all but as long as you're
driven by an interest in those things of
course you should do that and there's no
way I don't respect that that's a
perfectly valid thing to do
however in my case I have listened to
audio books on history and on literature
and have read books in certainly 18
languages so I've listened to history
books in Polish and Czech and in
Ukrainian and in Romanian even though I
don't speak the language very well and
not to mention German and Swedish and
French and Chinese and Japanese and
podcasts in Korea and so that's what I
like to do and that gives me a broader
range of experience through the language
a broader range of knowledge and I'm not
saying that what I do is superior but it
is it is a choice but the suggestion in
all these comments and maybe I'm
overreacting is that you know I have to
be blown away with what Matt is doing I
have to think that's tremendous I have
to go wow and that's obviously a
superior approach and it's just a choice
but but it is part of a broader picture
I was once at a conference here in
Vancouver
they talked about you know what was it
called dialoguing so you're not supposed
to disagree any longer you're just
supposed to kind of massage around and
come to the same kind of conclusion I
mean that's what's been a big part of
this whole political correctness thing
there is one correct way of doing things
and everybody must somehow coalesce
around this and I'm saying that in
history if Galileo didn't say that in
fact the Earth revolves around the Sun
if no one questioned church dogma if we
don't have lively debates about subjects
we're never going to get past the
established conventional wisdom and
therefore we should encourage people to
debate challenge what they're saying you
know by all means get in there and say I
don't like that because of this reason
and that reason but what we see more of
is this sort of you know why don't you
agree you know I find that even on I've
had the odd exchange on my channel here
where I ask people for their opinions
and someone comes forward with an
opinion and then I say well no actually
I don't agree with that I still feel the
way I originally felt and then the
person says well if he didn't want my
opinion why did you ask for it well I
didn't necessarily say that I was going
to agree with everything that people
said I'm just interested in hearing
other opinions because when we hear
other opinions and when we're involved
in a debate or a discussion we very very
rarely persuade other people that we are
right but we listen and as we listen we
learn things at the very least we're
forced to reassess our views and to
justify those views to ourselves and to
the other person whom we may not
persuade but at least we have to think
it through and it's also possible that
some of the things that the other person
says may influence how we feel but all
of that only happens if we can actually
have a debate and debates suggest that
we disagree and so I'm saying that
because I I just want to get this off my
chest I looked at those comments I'll
leave the link to Matt versus whatever
pants Steve whatever on his channel I
let him speak for 15 to 20 minutes or
hardly said anything and then I
commented on what I thought of his
approach and for whatever reason that
has earned the wrath of the vast
majority of his followers and I just
think it's unhealthy further to be that
degree of ill-will towards an opinion
that diverges from whatever is the sort
of conventional dogma amongst the
followers of the met and I say that
without wanting to take anything away
from Matt who is actually a very
pleasant person to talk to and who
speaks excellent Japanese and whom I
respect tremendously for what he has
done with his Japanese particularly
given the fact that he has only lived in
Japan for six months so he has learned
his Japanese essentially in the United
States and by the way I only say you
don't need to be in the country to learn
the language and being in the country
doesn't guarantee that you will learn
the language so in that sense Matt is
also proof of that so I just want to get
that off my chest it's out there and
probably will trigger a whole bunch more
negative comments but I think
particularly in this day and age when
there's so much sort of arrogance and
intolerance in how people present their
views we need to take a step back like
everything I say here now if somebody
wants to come along and produce a video
that totally disagrees with me that's
fine too but then I may come back and
disagree with that person in turn and
that's what's called open discussion
free discussion debate ideas challenging
each other and all of that can be done
without casting aspersions on the
person's character so thank you for
listening and there you have it
bye for now